you are watching Colchis chin
it's really amazing when you think about
the fact that full web browsing capable
app based smartphones have only been
around for seven years and just look how
they've changed the world the seventh
year 2014 is drawing to a close and we
have witnessed one of the most dynamic
rollercoaster rides are seen in the
mobile industry thus far we've had the
rise of China as a smartphone
manufacturing superpower we've had Apple
step into the phone tablet game we've
had Google changes strategy in the Nexus
6 going bigger and more expensive than
the floor price position that we're used
to and lastly we've had the final gasp
of breath from Nokia it seems as if 2013
was a completely different landscape in
this video we'll be taking a look at the
note 4 in terms of performance camera
design unique multitasking ability s-pen
abilities PC style use and a bit of a
look at the future into virtual reality
alright so let's get straight into it
starting with the build and the design
the note series has always had one
Achilles heel the build quality and as
discussed in the initial review the
build quality has been drastically
improved now it now has an echo of
elegance about it it feels very unlike
Samsung the chamfered metallic edges
really make the difference and you still
get to keep that removable back which is
a bonus as small as it sounds the
improvements in the response and travel
of the volume and power buttons really
makes a world of difference simply just
because you use them so often some of
the negative aspects would be the
speaker placement has returned to the
back of the phone and the audio output
itself is lacking a bit of fullness I've
also noticed that it's kind of easy to
get micro scratches on the screen so you
might want to be careful with that as
well
so summing it all up basically the
Samsung cheapness is gone I'm going to
give this an 8.5 out of 10 for build and
design all right so let's move on to the
display as mentioned in other videos the
screen is probably the most important
part of a modern-day smartphone and
without it you're severely limited so
it's important to take a look at the
display of this device it's a 5.7 inch
quad HD Super AMOLED display the pixel
density of 515 pixels per square inch
that makes it about 22% sharper than the
iPhone 6 plus this display and about 25
percent sharper than the note 3's
display purely from a pixel point of
view of course the screen is very bright
has very
viewing angles and you'll struggle to
see the pixels the screen does look
noticeably sharper than the 1080p panel
on the note 3 and you can notice this
most when web browsing the screen is 2.5
D which means it's slightly curved at
the edges this kind of gives you a sense
of tactile feedback so your fingers kind
of know when the edge of the screen is
going to come because of slightly tapers
down a little bit so this helps in
making swiping from the edges of the
screen just feel more natural to the
user so in summary it's actually a
surprisingly brilliant screen but some
people actually may find the colors a
little bit strong and the saturation a
bit too much for their liking that is
actually adjustable in the settings but
it really is up to your preference okay
so let's move on to the software so when
this phone was released it was running
Android KitKat 4.4 point 4 and lollipop
literally is pretty much here it's just
around the corner but unfortunately it
is touch was laid on top of Android
still on the bright side Samsung has
turned down the car two initiatives of
TouchWiz just that little bit so it's
not as jarring on the eye but that's
actually looking at the UI in general
when we actually come back to the home
screen it seems like the TouchWiz launch
it can just never be fixed
you'll probably be wise to replace it
with our home screen replacement such as
the nova launcher or the vox us launcher
from myself or just any other home
screen replacement that just really does
your phone wonders there's also been a
bit of attention paid to detail as well
now the dialog boxes have fade
transitions and in general the
animations are now smoother there's
either just a straight fade in well
there is a sense of motion physics to
the animations and they have some weight
to it instead of just popping out from
nowhere like they used to so there's a
couple of main things that set this
phone apart from just any other regular
phone and one of those would be
multitasking
now multitasking actually really makes
sense for a phone with such a large
screen I just have no idea why other
manufacturers don't take the initiative
and actually integrate this into their
phone software and not just in a subtle
sense but actually taking advantage of
that large screen format that a lot of
phones nowadays have it really is just a
huge ways to just have a big screen and
that's it just nothing else so with that
being said let's move on to the
multitasking I actually use this feature
each and every day I don't see how I'd
be able to get as much stuff done on
this phone without multitasking
sometimes I like to do multiple things
at once so
I'd like to stream music while web
browsing side get the desktop YouTube
player open in a windowed format and the
surprising thing is it's real
multitasking say the music still plays
and keeps on playing even though the
window has been minimized so with the
multitasking there's a few ways to do it
you can choose from a list of apps and
these are pretty determined so it's not
just any app that will actually work
with this but there are quite a few apps
and you can get most stuff done that you
need with the selection of apps provided
so multitasking this time around is
quite interesting this time you get
three ways of actually doing it the
first way is just the regular split
screen window so just two apps side by
side and another way is dragging in from
the corner either while split screened
or just by a single app and this creates
a smaller size adjustable window that
you can move around and the third way is
just by clicking on any app from the
multitasking area and that just gives
you a floating window as well so you can
have multiple floating windows for all
the multitasking you wish so you kind of
find yourself not having to wait for
things anymore so when something's
loading you can just whip up a quick
Google search or maybe just check some
emails or just do something else and
then when that thing's done you just
minimize the window I'll close it and
just get back to whatever you're doing
so it's just really a next level of
phone usage one of the cool thing is
that now phone calls themselves are
actually floating so when you get a
phone call the phone actually doesn't
just rip you out of what you are doing
and just throw you into the phone dialer
now it's actually just floating on top
so you can actually still do stuff while
the phone call was going that's kind of
Handy as well actually so that's not all
the windows are actually interactive so
you can actually drag and drop different
elements from window to window if you
say need and that kind of thing which is
kind of cool and all of this even makes
more sense when you start to use this as
a PC but we'll get to that in a little
bit so in total I give the software a
7.5 out of 10 and how you might be
thinking that's a little bit low out I
would give it a straight 10 out of 10 it
was made by someone else so say like HTC
with HTC Sense and just have that form
of elegance and flow that a basic UI is
supposed to but just seems that Samsung
just everything isn't just quite right
it just doesn't look quite right and
that's just their design language I
don't know why they do that so by all
means it's not a bad functioning set of
software it's just some of the
executional quirks that's all okay so
let's move on to something that sets the
fine apart from pretty much everything
else on the market at the moment and
that is the s-pen now physically the
s-pen is pretty much the same as it was
last time around except that now it has
twice the sensitivity so that's two
thousand levels of pressure sensitivity
versus one thousand on the note 3 so
what you get with that is just increased
responsiveness and it doesn't seem to
have this slight lag that it did before
and it's just slightly better right with
basically so there's quickly running
through some of the S Pen features if
you take out the S Pen and you click
over it you get this thing called Air
Command and really all of it is is just
a hub of different features that you can
quickly access with the S Pen so
starting with the left there's action
memo and what this basically does is
just puts up a quick memo sheet on top
of whatever you're doing and you can
obviously freely move it around and that
kind of thing well you can minimize it
if you like and if you wish by clicking
the bottom right hand corner you can
expand that into S note by clicking on
the icon to the right of the eraser the
software will recognize what you have
written if it's a phone number call
someone or or message that to someone or
email someone or you know search a
direction or that kind of thing so
there's just a whole bunch of options
there and it's pretty cool to have that
so next up we have smart select and this
basically just allows you to take
snapshots by cropping so you just select
your area that you want and you can use
this to put in a scrapbook or to send to
someone or to actually just convert it
into your text and next we have image
clip this allows you to freehand outline
whatever image you're looking to capture
and use it in a scrapbook or send it to
an individual or really just manipulate
it in a variety of different ways and
lastly we have screen right and this is
just to take a screenshot of your phone
and then you can annotate the different
things and obviously send it out and
edit it and that kind of thing so most
of these s-pen features are for content
creation on the device through things
like you know the internet and various
media that you can get on your device
directly so it's quite interesting and
I'm sure a lot of people that they would
find uses for for this kind of thing and
one more cool thing is if you've got a
whole bunch of text to select you can
just literally press the S Pen down and
it will start highlighting and then you
can press the action button and drag
diagonally and or select text just as a
mouse would do it quite interesting for
PC use okay so we're just over halfway
through the review let's take a quick
break and then we'll be back with
performance and PCs and all that cool
stuff the Samsung Galaxy Note 4 is one
of the flagship phones of this year so
it's bound to have some pretty good
performance let's take a look at that
right now
so the source of power from this device
stems from three processors a 32-bit
quad-core Snapdragon 805 or 32 and
64-bit version of an 8 core Exynos 5 4
33 no matter which version you pick up
you're still going to get fast frame
rates and both gaming and UI navigation
but that's not the whole story
there's actually an unexplainable delay
when hitting the multitasking button
it's only for about just under a second
but it's noticeable and I've had some
pauses here and there at times for no
reason really now don't get me wrong
this doesn't happen often and the pauses
are usually for about a second but
really for a phone with this kind of
caliber of specifications I can't it
still is really a mystery to me but on
the bright side the famous Samsung
lockscreen delay has gone and now the
screen fades in and out when you lock
and unlock the device for just that
extra bit of polish overall I'd say it's
a very quick device and you should have
no problems with performance well I'm
giving the performance a solid 9 out of
10 but what about using it as a PC let's
take a bit of a look at that so when I
was using this device as a PC I used a
regular Logitech mouse and an Apple
keyboard with this enhance multitasking
you can do things a lot easier
one thing I'm fond of is that web
applications like the desktop version of
YouTube actually work fine this comes in
handy when some videos are blocked for
mobile use and that kind of thing
there's now zero typing delay and it
feels pretty natural and all of that
extra screen resolution over last year's
model does provide the few benefits now
the floating window text is readable and
it actually looks pretty decent
fortunately some elements of the UI are
still a little bit too large take the
floating windows themselves for example
on the negative side performance also
does take a slight hit when displaying
natively at 2k resolution and externally
at 1080p simultaneously 3 gigabytes of
RAM should be enough for that so I'm
assuming that the bottleneck is at the
CPU or GPU level I was once again
impressed by using the device in this
way and I do see some potential in
something like a Chrome OS and a Bunty
combined system set up for something
like this if someone does it right this
could really be something of course I'm
going to go into more detail in the PC
style use in a separate video but as for
now you can know it works well ok so
let's take a quick look at the camera
before I get talking them this is
probably worth mentioning that I've
already done a quick camera sample shot
video so you can take a look at that in
the description below it's quite
interesting it's got a few macro shots
which aren't regularly seen on phones so
the depth of field is actually really
good for a mobile device so can check
that out if you want this camera is a 16
megapixel shooter and it does shoot at
4k but the thing that sets it apart is
that does have optical image
stabilization and this is the first in
any samsung galaxy phone apart from the
zoom series so overall it takes really
good photos and videos but some people
may notice that it's a bit over
sharpened now it's not the end of the
world but you may find that some photos
don't look 100% natural videography is
also quite fun with the optical image
stabilization making it easier to get
some nice steady looking shots and of
course slow motion video makes return
with the ability to shoot at 240 frames
per second at 720p so as you can see
here this was just something randomly
happening at my shopping centre down the
road and yeah as you can see it turns
out pretty interesting and you can just
seal all the details that happen so
quickly in real life and it's just kind
of fun so overall I give the camera
about an 8.5 out of 10 few points
deducted for the over sharpening and
fairly poor low-light performance it is
improved over last year's Galaxy Note 3
but it's still not the best in the world
and here's an example of that this is
just some random low-light shots that I
took and as you can see some of the
footage is just a little bit grainy okay
so that covers most things we're almost
done with the review but before we
finish off and know you wrap this up
let's just go over a couple of quick
things
firstly the battery life so in here
you're getting a three thousand two
hundred and twenty milliamp hour battery
and it can quickly charge from zero to
fifty percent in about thirty minutes
which is very very handy and I and I
really like the better in this device
looking at about five to six hours of
screen on time and you should be able to
get through a full day with would
moderate to heavy use and once again it
does depend on which version of the
phone you pick up some people have said
that they've had a not as good battery
life but for me personally and this
phone that I've had battery life has
been quite good I wouldn't say you would
have to worry about carrying a second
battery or something like that and
finally something that's a bit different
that no other phone manufacturer has
done actually and that is virtual
reality and this is going to be coming
to the note series quite soon so for
those of you that don't know virtual
reality is a technology that has existed
for the better part of three decades now
but it has never really been realized
until earlier last year when a company
called oculus released a virtual reality
headset and it was spearheaded by a man
called John Carmack and this was the guy
that basically invented side scrolling
for PC before was only a console thing
back in the early 90s and also created
basically 3d gaming with his home built
game engine for games such as
Wolfenstein 3d and doom so he is a big
big player in the game industry and so
he worked on this virtual reality
headset yes up just since then the
virtuality community has started to take
off and now Samsung has teamed up with
oculus and John Carmack and together
they've released this virtual reality
headset system for the Galaxy Note 4 so
virtual reality is a thing that is hard
to demonstrate but really it is what it
sounds like it is an entire world where
you put on these goggles and there's an
entire world that you can explore and
feel like you're totally immersed within
this other realm so it's an interesting
technology and um
Samsung is spearheading this at the very
forefront of a mobile version of this
with the note 4 so the way it works is
the note 4 will act as the virtual
reality screen and then there will be a
system called the gear VR which will act
as the goals and basically the rest of
the virtual reality systems all you have
to do is slot your phone into the
of the gear VR and then you have a
virtual reality system where you can
play games or just watch movies inside a
virtual cinema so basically you can turn
around and see the seats behind you or
that kind of thing so yeah a whole bunch
of stuff happening with virtual reality
and it's going to be interesting to see
what Samsung does in the future with
that and as a side point me and a friend
are working on a virtual reality app for
the gear system so we'll see how that
goes so on that note I think it is time
to conclude this review so what have we
learnt so far the Galaxy Note 4 is a
great all-round phone that does a bit of
everything and does it all fairly well
so with an industry that's getting more
and more crowded in phone tablets making
the transformation of being laughed at
to being the global trend the note 4 is
in a good position right now and sum it
up succinctly in one sentence the note 4
is the note series realized and done
right
all the little improvements over last
year's model really created a pleasing
synergy that was a major improvement
over every note or any previous Samsung
device for that matter so what is the
overall score well this phone receives
an 85 percent which is a very solid
score and with all the additional
features some of which I didn't even go
through the valley is much greater than
most of the competition out there so if
you're looking for a premium device and
you just want to go out there and get
the very best I say this phone is
definitely one you should look at anyway
this has been cold fusion thank you for
sitting down and choosing to click on
this video right here on YouTube and as
usual don't forget to rate comment and
subscribe and if you like this video and
think that someone would benefit from
what I've said feel free to send a link
across so you can share it and yeah
until next time I'll catch you again
soon for the next video and enjoy the
rest of your day guys everyone Cheers
cold future
it's rethinking